hello and welcome to this video only on
24 fil mendoza okay do we get something
funky the Swiss line is always leading
to weird positions but now we transpose
to a traditional bank oh yeah that's
what's the check the check and before
yeah I don't know it's a night really
great on c2 i don't i don't know i
actually have my doubts but we'll see I
can go 94 in this position as well it's
an idea just just grab the bishop pair
while it's available
[Music]
okay I just I just play a normal stuff
maybe here this is not that bad night
night on III might make some sense
actually to play against f5 anyway it
cannot be completely bad okay so
probably we need to regroup here a
little bit the Queen side is totally
close to and play is going to happen
mostly on the Kings side
so a five no that's just too much too
much going on on f 50 both nights the
bishop and so on so here he tre he
louses trade it's a bit surprising it
helps me a little bit i think those
traits do help because of my lack of
space you probably go back to G to know
true that is possible
I didn't anticipate that at all DM and
then he's got nine f3 oh my God look
good no Paul laughs I was far by far too
relaxed him i'm not paying enough
attention to what he's doing if i push
lg4 maybe that's still kind of holds but
pretty awful Wow yeah this force where I
was just like not I wasn't paying enough
attention
the beginning I felt that was relatively
harmless but now it definitely is not I
mean definitely not white is just better
and g5 is a kinda move that kind of says
you know things went wrong and it's
going to be ugly it's this this this set
bad interesting I has it ever like how
quickly can you play I mean it said all
that is here doesn't doesn't feel feel
that easy as you wrong to me I always
think it's not that easy but then they
play almost immediately and kill me
which is six
check this wasn't wasn't clear to me
with it's obviously very clear to him as
he is not spending a single second on
anything so check here on f4 time
morning check check check
okay I can take here check this and then
I'm just winning right check it's either
made or look at three takes d3 quite
resigned yeah why do you have to play
like everything in one second I mean
white position was fantastic you have
thought well the engine doesn't agree
okay strange hmm I thought why does
better here engine likes this move why I
thought this is just like pointless but
g5 okay hey wrong and now you cannot
take yeah I think just judge just losers
right at five don't care for is this
problems all over the place they are
those in two media checks I think yeah
this is also I think wins but this is
fairly fairly clean as this is a maid
checkmate and check this is blundering
the bishop on d3 so it's fairly fairly
straightforward I really thought I'm in
trouble here but it seems I questioned
94 actually this I mean in general i
like to trade a bit here because of my
space disadvantage but f-for kind of
thought called me wrong footed but it
doesn't seem to be the best so bad i was
also kind of afraid that some lady five
would work I mean I have Bishop g4 that
was my plan but I still thought it might
work because of the pretty awkward piece
placement
something like this but okay i thought
this and maybe now I'm losing something
but it doesn't seem to be the case d6
doesn't seem to win it looks a bit
awkward because my pieces are so bad so
far back but it doesn't doesn't really
it is not that bad i saw this two- Luke
83 is stronger I didn't see a move okay
interesting game thanks for watching